see as I go to the street people know me
well enough to be able to feel they can
talk and come up to me and say look I
want to ask you something
fine let's talk and I keep an ear to the
ground
people are always by Etta politicians
always politicians hear what they want
to hear people hear what they have to
hear a lot of people don't know but
Virginia has the smallest voting
population of minority black voting
population of any of the southern states
it's only about 15% you were surprised
the other most people don't know that
which means I had to go out into the
community to that other 85% of the
people and where did I go first place I
started my campaign was done in South
West Virginia coal mining country went
into the mines talk to the people stayed
in their homes I never would stay in
hotels I owned that stays in the homes
of the people that I met or that I had
known from my legislative experiences I
never campaigned didn't campaign only
hello states I campaign on the country
stores in the barbershops and I was
learned I was learning back one of my
friends from Southwest Virginia said
don't you go into these country stores
now or whatever you go you've got to
shake every hand because miss anybody
they're gonna tell it and if you'd
missed one store they're gonna tell it
all right so I went to this door and see
he said because the bread mass would be
there or the coca-cola man's gonna be an
instant well I was down at that store no
he's coming to your place
I also learned going to the local
newspapers in the local radio
establishments people read that local
because they listen to their local
radios and I went to everyone and they
welcomed you
now also like to emphasize that estate
sixty days straight campaigning across
every independent city in town in
Virginia some near 300 and I never had a
single person to refuse to shake my hand
never or to deny me access for being
able to run and I was pleased with the
reception and they give you an
illustration how you can't take people
for granted I went into one store the
man was sitting there with bib overalls
I sick I shook everybody's hands and
I've gone through and getting relief
somebody with me said you didn't shake
this man's hand
oh good file back that's it hi I'm Doug
wild I'm running for governor wants you
to look at my and I used to carry our
grip card we call it my left hand and
that would take it in my hand and get
that to the person that I shake the
right hand and then I'd always wait to
look behind as I was leaving to see if
they thought it into the trash yet so I
did that to everybody and says of
leaving somebody said hey you didn't
shake that man's hand over there I see
you arrest I went over the man was
sitting on on a barrel top of a barrel
with a straw hat on be overalls red
bandana around his neck
tobacco greases in his jaws like that I
said Sam Dockweiler
and I'm just wondering your vote want to
ask you it wanted to want to know if you
would read this symptom he's no thought
you come passed me by
no noise at some time I asked you
that's it that's that's what I mean he
said I won't talk about this abortion
that's all my god I couldn't
got noticed at all I did after state
yeah and I get him as I started my
Jeffersonian spiel government has no
right to interfere the most personal
preset ain't no man's business no way is
it Wow now who would have believed that
man sitting on that barrel looking as I
described it
what have that view back in 1989
Virginia Southwest Virginia but he did
there was such an awakening experience
for me it reinforced my belief that you
don't judge people by how they look how
they talk how they walk or where they
live it reinforced what I was raised to
believe that we are the same people we
just need to see more of it there are
more things that connect us and unites
us than divide us we should emphasize
that where do you think this disconnect
comes from there are so many places you
could put it there are many people who
have moved government to being
professional politics to be professional
I'm still guided by the simplicity of
Lincoln of the people for the vehicle
other people I think it comes from over
valuing the estimation of those who
service pundits look how they totally
missed this last election totally and
still haven't recovered from it
in terms of saying yeah we were wrong
you just can't say hey look we don't get
this right what is it that you didn't
get right know anybody that takes a poll
every day to find out what's going on in
to you that's not that's not that that's
not the name of what America is where we
are today in America is a recent four
period Bernie Sanders was hitting on the
Left what Donald Trump was hitting on
the right I saw something there I saw
people becoming disaffected on the
Democratic side I saw people on the
Republican side not being United at all
no one would have believed I lost money
I thought Jeb Bush would have been the
nominee I voted for Hillary Clinton but
I also knew that in so doing she needed
a relativity that's why I supported Tim
Kaine because I thought that he could
provide that as it turned out
unfortunately that he wasn't utilized in
the ways that I thought he'd may have
been utilized and Trump moved into the
vacuum so where we are today we're in as
Theodore white would say in some of his
books he wrote making of the president
and the last one I read that he wrote
was called America in search of itself
and he says every 30 years or so there's
a cyclic reform that takes place in
America we are still in search of
ourselves can we get where we need to be
yes but we won't do it with rancor and
finger pointing as Lyndon Johnson would
say come let us
together do you think it has maybe
something to do some people have brought
up about maybe diversifying the the
people that are out there for people to
maybe maybe seeing more of themselves
maybe my more minority raspberr
representation and maybe even more
minority involvement in politics all
right as I said to someone yesterday we
have more minority representation in
America today than ever in the history
of the country I think better or worse
and I leave that answer to you but I
will further respond to you by saying
that's not the answer the question isn't
who who you were the representatives our
government is the people choice I keep
going back to Lincoln it's simple if we
have those who understand that that
responsibility is to represent us not
themselves and that in so doing if they
don't we'll say thank you we don't need
you anymore
we'll get those who can and if what
you're doing isn't proposing to be
representative of us we want that
changed by the next group of people we
put there no I don't think the answer
comes as unnecessary racial quarter
basis or increasing that number and the
question is in America the
representation of people has grown to
being more self serving than serving the
people
look at Lyndon Johnson who was likewise
the president of all people but he
fought for Thurgood Marshall to be put
on a bench he used this persuasive
capacity to get Eastland of Mississippi
and Georgia decided from Georgia Richard
Russell to come around to understand
look look I'm gonna do this now now you
tell me what you need now having said
that I think Obama really did try was
one of the first persons to publicly
come hope that had political status to
endorsed Obama Hillary had everybody
yeah most of the black caucus there were
very few people endorsing Obama I did
because of that birthing you mentioned
the hope the possibilities
now I having said that one of the things
that I hear so much of Thurgood Marshall
was more than just a vote on the Supreme
Court pension
I knew him personally I've worked with
him because he had appointed me to be
the his Virginia representative for the
n-double-a-cp legal defense and
education fund succeeded Spofford
Robinson or Sophie laughs and that is
what is here in the book as well
ah there are good spent time educating
their other members of the bench saying
look this is what we're talking about
this is more than just black and white
terms of a law this is what this effect
is and this is the lack of it his
contributions really haven't been
measured in that regard but the effect
of it has been to the contrary
Clarence Thomas has made it clear to you
that I do not I'm not here to represent
those people I represent everybody look
at the decisions that have come in eight
to one with Thomas being against civil
rights proposals man beaten almost to
death at a prison in Georgia and the
court decided that his civil rights have
been violated
Thomas supported little now why do I
give you that backdrop because people
are saying who represents that group of
people on the Supreme Court today
who would you describe as being the
representative of the black voice on the
Supreme Court
you wouldn't say Thomas right no what if
the President had three chances to at
least name a black person whether that
person got nominated or not don't get
confirmed or not at least show your
belief that didn't happen
very few president most presidents don't
get a chance to name one that beateth
some of the things he did I can't
applaud any more so that have been
applauded but closing Guantanamo of
course pulling us out of these wars we
shouldn't have been in of course but
it's difficult but the time spent in
doing that takes away from the positives
that he could have and unfortunately
those who were in many instances
advising him spent more time saying this
would be the safer course to take take
the road less traveled sometimes hey
whether it's safe or not to make a rule
make a highway where there was only a
path and I think I've always been a good
president it's too early to talked about
the legacy but people who or who thought
that their time had come
unfortunately there would be those who
were saying to them you had your chance
this is a new day
that's unfortunate I don't think
cyclically events should be a part of
the governing process
in America because it still goes back to
think of the people for the people by
the people do you think that speaks to a
lack of understanding of race relations
in this country that maybe this is just
these issues we're just going to ignore
and set aside well that was then you
know look just get past that no one else
gets past the deprivation of the past
they address them have we or do we and
unfortunately it's not a matter of an
apology but America has never been a
great nation how can we go back to what
we weren't we are still in search of
ourselves that education process has to
take place whether it's rooted in the
home or in the community
the unfortunate thing in America today
is we've lost the communities is it
irreparable no can we reclaim them yes
how do we do that it's not just by
saying listen to what I say I am your
leader I'm your representative I tell
the steel of ropes bi when the French
Revolution and the crowd was charging
the Bastille and his tale was told that
he was inside drinking wine and looking
out of his mansion to well those people
going after all I am their leader
there's no such thing as that so today
we need to drill down drill back bind
our wounds and as Anna Johnson said
again come let us reason together there
has to be a reason there has to be a
recognition of their more that unites us
than divides us let's get past that
this Memorial in downtown Richmond pays
tribute to the Virginia statute for
religious freedom enacted by the state's
General Assembly on January 16 1786 and
penned by Thomas Jefferson it addresses
the principle of separation of church
and state
the three-paragraph statute is the basis
for our First Amendment protections for
religious freedom up next we learn about
another founding father and the
financial scandal that landed him in
prison
Robert Morris was an incredibly
important American founder but it's true
that not very many people know about him
he was the financier of the American
Revolution so-called because he served
as the superintendent of Finance towards
the end of the American Revolution and
he really helped put that early
government on a sound financial footing
when it was in big trouble at the end of
the war so he was a money man he's also
not very well known because of what
happened to him at the end of his life
he messed up pretty bad he was one of
the richest guys in the country after
the American Revolution he was a very
important senator from Pennsylvania but
at the end of his life he ended up
losing basically all of his fortune and
went to debtors prison and when he came
out of debtors prison the country did
not have very fond feelings for him and
so he ended up being more or less
forgotten for the next few generations I
like to tell the story of Robert Morris
is something like rags to riches and
then back to rags again because he
started off from pretty humble
circumstances he was born in Liverpool
in England we don't think that his
parents were married originally his dad
ended up coming over to America as a
tobacco factor as a as a worker in the
tobacco industry and so he was brought
over as a 13 or 14 year old boy to live
with his father in Maryland and ended up
not liking Maryland and wanted to go to
the big city and so his father arranged
for Robert Morris to move up to
Philadelphia and once he settled in
Philadelphia he found his niche
he ended up apprenticing at a merchants
firm and proved to be really a prodigy
when it came to trading and accounting
and doing all the things that merchants
were doing at the time and so he rose
quickly in the ranks and a chief partner
at a firm when he was was quite young so
he didn't have a whole lot of formal
education it was all on the job and that
was pretty much characteristic of him
throughout his life he he wasn't one of
the more intellectual or cerebral
founders he was a guy who liked doing
and he had a kind of a common touch as
well he'll I
to drink you like to eat he liked to
sing songs at the pub with his club club
friends and so he was more of a rowdy
rougher around the edges founder than
most of us think of when we think of
that set of folks he was less of a
politician in what we traditionally
think of of the term when the big
question of Independence finally came in
1776 whether to sign the Declaration of
Independence or to support that movement
and so Robert Morris was I'd say
hesitant about declaring independence he
didn't think it was something that would
be helpful in the short term he thought
maybe in a long term this would be
something to work towards and so he was
not he took himself out of the meeting
when it came time to actually vote for
independence but in the next month or so
once they brought the declaration around
for though all the signatures he signed
on and pledged pledged his fortune for
the war effort and kind of arrests
through his fate in with everybody else
as we know Philadelphia was a key city
for initiating the American Revolution
this is where the Continental Congress
was meeting and this is where a lot of
American trade was taking place and so
when the Congress started meeting there
and when the colony of Pennsylvania
started to think about what it was going
to do in terms of the crisis with Great
Britain he was swept into that as as a
rich guy as a merchant who had something
to say about how trade was going to
happen or was not going to happen with
the mother country and so he ended up
being a member of the Continental
Congress quite early he was also active
in the colony or the state politics once
the state had declared its independence
and so he was important for the
Continental Congress early on because he
was one of those traders that the
Congress tapped to help them find arms
and ammunition for the war effort the
colonies up and down the East Coast
didn't have a big army or a big Navy
ready to go and so they needed to find
those kinds of supplies to make the war
effort happen and so he was tapped as
one of those
behind-the-scenes workers that were
arranging for loans and for weapons and
for supplies to make the war effort go
there's a anecdote I don't know if it's
true or not but it's kind of
symbolically true and that when one of
the generals was looking for ammunition
and there was no ammunition to be had
one of Morris's ships came in and Morris
was able to find lead ballast in the
bottom of a ship and that they then
turned into cartridges the other kind of
anecdote that is often told about Morris
during the war that kind of personifies
his approach to keeping the war effort
going was when the soldiers were headed
towards Yorktown they paused and kind of
put in a little bit of a mutiny to say
that they did not want to go any further
without getting paid they had not been
paid for months and so Morris was able
to receive hard money from the French
that he was able to borrow and then take
down directly to the soldiers so that
they would have pay enough that they
could send back to their families so
that they could feel good about
continuing on to Yorktown and then
ultimately winning the war but mostly
how he helped with the war effort was
providing money for it finding loans
either among the American population or
abroad with France or the Netherlands or
Spain or some of the other countries
that were willing to loan this fledgling
government money so that they were able
to pay their bills we're all pretty much
familiar with what a Continental dollar
was worth and it wasn't worth very much
and so there needed to be a constant
supply of funds and loans to keep this
army in the field really George
Washington had a lot of patience as
commander-in-chief and so he had a good
poker face and that he would always
approach Congress and try to let them
know the kind of dire situation that his
army was in and the kind of needs that
his soldiers had in order to continue
fighting but Congress was not very well
organized in terms of providing the kind
of supplies and funding that the army
really needed they basically relied on a
on a voluntary donation basis from each
of the states to make sure that their
Treasury had enough to run on and the
states were always kind of running
behind with what they were supposed to
provide and so Washington would
oftentimes turn to Morris personally as
a way to appeal to someone within the
Congress and then when Morris became
superintendent of Finance especially
towards the end of the war as someone
who could personally move the levers of
government and provide the army with the
kind of resources that it needed when
the committees or the just the general
Congress itself or the states more
largely were unable to provide that kind
of support and so Washington wasn't very
close to a lot of people throughout his
life he was very famous for being
standoffish as been keeping counsel to
himself as being a little bit of a stoic
but he seemed to really let his guard
down around Robert Morris I think he
found a soul that he felt like he could
trust that had been there for him when
he really needed it and so I think we
could consider Morris oddly one of
George Washington's closest friends when
the war was over he was quite relieved
he didn't think he could get out of the
position that he was in fast enough at
the end of the war for the last I guess
from 1781 to 1789 tenant of Finance
which was really the most important
minister of the congressional government
at the time there was no president under
the Articles of Confederation and so he
had his hands full he couldn't meet all
the obligations that were coming in at
him and so he did his best to organize
it but it was a frustrating position and
he wasn't ever one that had a real
appetite for politics to begin with he
didn't see himself as a statesman he
didn't like to give big speeches on
things that wasn't really his ambition
he was very ambitious but it was more in
terms of his own personal Empire his
checkbook his balance sheet and all of
his friends that he liked to associate
with and so once the peace came and he
felt like he had provided a sound
financial footing for the Confederation
government as best he could he was very
happy to move into private life again
and so private life for Morris meant
being incredibly busy in almost every
Arina of the economy he was involved in
some of the earliest trades to china
from america directly and so he financed
the early Chinese voyages for trade he
was very active in a factory complex
that was on the falls of the Delaware
River where he had various clothing and
nail making and breweries and other kind
of industrial operations there he was
trading debts government debts and
trading Bills of exchange kind of the
private currency of the time and he was
still a merchant in some way what he had
built his fortune on but mostly what he
got excited about after the war was land
speculation he felt like this was a very
optimistic time for America that this
was a country that would had a bright
future ahead of it and so he couldn't
wait to kind of provide himself with the
kind of resources that would surely
increase in value which would be all
these millions and millions of acres
that had now opened up for the United
States according to the peace treaty and
so he sunk most of his fortune and most
of his energies into acquiring just
millions of acres of land
it's oosting that at the period of time
where he's making all of these
incredible land purchases and he feels
like he's on the top of the world he
signs on to build a house in
Philadelphia that's like nothing else
that had ever been built in America
really the closest parallel to it would
be the president's house in Washington
DC what we call now the White House
before that in Philadelphia the very
wealthiest people live mostly in what
we'd call row houses which were
phenomenally appointed which were
beautiful which had a lot of space
plenty of living space but looked more
or less uniform throughout the city in
that it was a regular streetscape but
Morris decided that he wanted something
much different than that so he bought an
entire city block of land about two
blocks away from the houses of Congress
and in its Hall where the state
government met and he hired Pierre
L'Enfant the engineer who had designed
the city of Washington DC to design this
house for him and
two came up with an incredible design it
was it was a Parisian based mansion
really a palace is what people called it
and it was going to be wider than the
Pennsylvania State House it was going to
be bigger than any other house in the
city and it started construction
just as Morris's affairs start to
unravel but Mora still felt like he
could build the thing and so they
constructed the house over a period of
about five years four or five years and
it got as high as the roof and it was an
incredible roof itself that was a
mansard roof which was a French style
that it really hadn't been built in
America before and the workers that were
building it were Italian stone masons
stone carvers there were plasterers from
Europe there were local Philadelphia
carpenters and brick Masons and just
dozens and dozens of workers that work
season after season on this house and
the irony of it all was that Morris and
his family were never able to live in
the house just as it was about to be
able to be opened for the family
Morris lost all of his money and went to
debtors prison and so it was something
that the locals ended up calling
Morris's folly and so the house ended up
standing in for really Morris's
financial poor decisions and so the
house became a symbol for Morris's
failed ambition because it was never
really completed and it was torn down
shortly afterwards and so rather than
proceeding at a more cautious pace or
trying to wrap up some of these big
dealings he keeps on with them and so he
starts to really get in trouble I would
say in a significant way in 1795 or 1796
where he and one of his main partners a
guy named John Nicholson have to end up
basically creating their own type of
currency they called them eminence after
Morris and Nicholson's and they would
try to sign for each other little checks
that they were then try to pay their
creditors for and as they tried to do
this over a period of a year or two they
had thousands and thousands
of dollars that they had essentially
created that after a short period of
time would become due with real money or
with real credit and that ended up being
just a spiral that he and his partner
could not get out of
and so by 1797 things had gotten so bad
for Morris that he actually retreated
out of his family's home in the center
of Philadelphia and left to live on his
country estate outside of town about
three miles of the Schuylkill River and
he retreated into his home there and the
sheriff's were trying to apprehend him
and bring him to debtors prison but
there was a rule that says that the
sheriff's could not break and enter into
someone's private home and so as long as
he was behind his bar doors he could
maintain his operations and he thought
again that he could keep pulling himself
out of this that the tide would soon
turn that it was just around the corner
that these sales were gonna happen and
that his credit would come back into
full bloom again but by 1798 February he
had run out of time and he saw the
writing on the wall and he eventually
gave himself up to the sheriff and was
sent to debtors prison his friends stuck
with him throughout he even made friends
in prison this was a guy who was a very
gregarious who loved people and couldn't
even make new friends while disgraced in
prison and his most famous friend of
course remained George Washington and in
1798 shortly after Morris had been
imprisoned Washington was back in
Philadelphia out of retirement to take
over or to help train really the United
States Army because of tensions with
France at the time and one of
Washington's stops in the city when he
was in Philadelphia was to go visit his
old friend Robert Morris in debtors
prison and so we know that the two had a
meal there and with Robert Morris's wife
and with his daughter and so we can only
imagine that scene with George
Washington here this general the
president's seated inside Morris's
little cell and the debtors apartment
and the kind of bittersweet reunion that
that must have been but at the same time
Washington was concerned to do the right
thing was concerned to follow the laws
of the country
and so never sought to do anything that
would go against what put Morris in
debtors prison in the first place and
some worse excuse me
and so Washington never took any direct
steps to try to free Morris from prison
and neither did really any of his other
friends as well he was on his own at
that point in 1801 he got out of prison
and he was tremendously relieved in the
end he decided that it was a good thing
to be out of prison rather than to be in
prison Robert Morris occasionally tried
to break back into the merchant merchant
business or the banking business or the
land business but he was never really
able to get anything off the ground it's
it's kind of ironic one of his
politically enemies Thomas Jefferson who
had a very different approach to the
nation's future than Robert Morris did
Thomas Jefferson wondered aloud to his
friend James Madison about the
possibility of Robert Morris serving as
the Secretary of the Navy underneath
Thomas Jefferson when Jefferson was
elected president but Jefferson
acknowledged that Morris was still in
disgrace and that it would be really
impossible to um point Morris to his
cabinet but it's interesting that there
is some good feelings towards horses
abilities but also some skepticism as to
his reputation and his fate it's a weird
moment for Robert Morris in that his
protege Alexander Hamilton we all know
about the Broadway play has been
spectacular it's it's created a
tremendous amount of interest in
Alexander Hamilton and in the nation's
early finances and yet they're in the
shadows remains Robert Morris there
hasn't been a whole lot of studies of
him that's one of the things that drew
me to a study of Morris and to his house
which no one had really spent much time
studying either and so I tried to focus
on a particular element of the last part
of his life and and again the house as a
lens through which we can understand not
only Morris but the challenges that
America faced overall in the 1790s and
frankly that we still face today this
question of what did the very
richest Americans kind of owe their
fellow-citizens are there limits on what
the richest Americans can or should be
able to do and so Morris's life and his
end particularly help show how Americans
have thought about that question and
wrestled with that question
continuing our look at Richmond this is
the city's famed Monument Avenue with
statues honoring Confederate war heroes
including robert e lee Thomas Stonewall
Jackson and Jefferson Davis in 1996
African American tennis star and
Richmond native Arthur Ashe was added to
the collection conversations about
Monument Avenue and which statues should
be added changed or removed continue
today
up next we speak with Kristen green on
the fight to desegregate Prince Edward
County Virginia
Brown versus Board of Education I think
a lot of people believe that it is just
one court case that's what I thought of
it as you know growing up and I also
think that people believe that as soon
as the decision was handed down by the
Supreme Court in 1954 that it was
immediately implemented and that also is
not not true so what I learned working
on research for the book was that Prince
Edward County not only was really
affected by the Brown versus Board of
Education decision but it was actually
one of five cases that was rolled into
an umbrella Brown case and the reason
that Prince Edward was part of the Brown
versus Board of Education decision was a
young woman named Barbara John's a high
school junior led a walkout to protest
the conditions of her school Moton High
School in Farmville Virginia in 1951 and
that walkout attracted the attention of
n-double-a-cp attorneys in Richmond and
they agreed to come meet with Barbara
John's and her fellow students and their
parents but that decision led the
n-double-a-cp to take up the case and
file a lawsuit on behalf of those
students and that eventually made it all
the way to the Supreme Court as part of
Brown versus Board of Education and it
was the only student-led case out of the
five and County leaders there were so
stunned by the decision as were you know
Virginia leaders and and leaders across
the south and the country but I think
Prince Edward County leaders felt
particularly embarrassed and
particularly nervous that they would be
held up as an example and forced to
integrate before communities across the
nation did and so they really took
measures that other communities didn't
seem she is necessary to prevent them
from having to integrate their schools
and they began conversations very early
about what they would do if they were
put in the position that they would have
to disarray their schools so within six
months of the decision being handed down
the white run newspaper the FarmVille
Herald was calling for
community leaders to do anything but
desegregate their schools and said you
know if push came to shove that they
should shut the schools rather than
desegregate them and so you know right
at the gate white leaders in that
community we're calling for these
drastic measures to avoid desegregation
Prince Edward County is located it's
kind of considered the heart of Virginia
that's what they call themselves and
they're located about an hour and
fifteen minutes
south west of Richmond the demographics
in the era of the the school walkout in
this case we're pretty equals pretty
much like 5050 blacks and whites and
some people believe that that is part of
what led to this pushback by white
members not white white leaders of the
community not to decelerate the schools
and and instead to close the schools
there's a belief that because the black
population of Prince Edward County was
was higher than it was in other parts of
the states perhaps white leaders felt
threatened felt they needed to do more
to control blacks leaders white leaders
were pretty upset about the walkout and
I think they were embarrassed and wait
you know white leaders had refused to
provide a better school a bigger school
for black students and Families for so
long they had done these these measures
like the tarpaper shacks which were just
really stopgap measures and we're not
appropriate and so when when the court
when the case went to the courts white
leaders decided to move ahead with
building a new school for a new black
high school for the black students and I
think that they hoped that this would
you know put a stop to the lawsuit and
you know detract attention from them so
I think that the plan was to you know if
they if they built this new high school
then the black families would get what
they wanted
and and the lawsuit would go away so it
wasn't until the summer of 1959 that the
order was handed down for Prince Eric
County to finally dis area at schools
and at that point County leaders were
prepared they had in recent years had
gone to a month-to-month funding system
so that if they needed to shut down the
schools they could do it at a moment's
notice and so they you know and they had
been preparing this idea for having
private schools in church basements and
social halls and they had gotten pledges
of money from white members of the
community so they were really ready to
go and you know when when this happened
and so as they had promised they did
exactly what they suggest that they
would do and county leaders voted not to
fund public education which essentially
shut the schools that summer and so
white leaders launched into action
trying to make those pledges become real
dollars and setting out to find churches
and social halls all over the county
where white children could be educated
so that they wouldn't have to miss a
single day of school I think black
community members and leaders were
really taken off off guard when white
leaders voted to close the schools they
just they viewed it as a threat they
didn't think anybody would really you
know go through with that and so even
after the vote was taken you know
n-double-a-cp attorneys were like you
know the schools aren't closed yet
they're not gonna do this and so there
was a real sense that that this wasn't
going to be the reality right that was
part of the problem and the other
problem was that you know there was no
way for anybody to know how long the
schools would be closed I mean certainly
no one imagined that they would be
closed you know more than a year even if
they could actually see them being
closed in 1959 it was hard for anybody
to imagine that he closed for more than
a year so the schools ended up being
closed for five full school years and
families took really different actions
during that time you know many many
we're not able to send their kids
anywhere during that time and so some of
the local churches got together and
offered training centers in the basement
of the churches and they really weren't
schools they weren't meant to be schools
because there was this idea floated by
the white community that a private
school should be opened for the black
children just like they had down and for
the white children but you know black
leaders knew that would work against
their cause of desegregation and they
they shut that down quickly so the
training centers were more a way to keep
children engaged but they were not meant
to be like a full school day and they
were taught by volunteers so that was an
option for some kids there were you know
there are so many examples of what
people did but some children or snuck
across county lines you know every day
to go to school in adjacent County I
write about one dad who rented a house
in an adjacent County and he made it
look like they lived there and then he
would drop his kids off behind the house
every day on his way to work at the
railroad and he had instructed the
children not to enter the house until
they heard the bus coming down the
county roads and only then were they to
walk through the back of the house
through the house out the front door you
know through the yard and up the steps
of that big bus and never were they to
tell anyone that they did not live there
because he knew that their education was
at stake and he when that worked
successfully he invited some of his
friends to drop their children off there
and pretty soon 21 kids were getting on
the bus there and the bus driver would
just laugh and say there's no way you
guys are all siblings a lot of them were
in the same grades you know it's clear
they weren't blood relatives but this
was one way that you know some kids got
educated there were a lot of other kids
who went to live with relatives
elsewhere particularly in the north
there were you know at some point the
Quakers got involved and offered to
match children with families elsewhere
in the US and so some some of these
students went to live with white
families in Ohio there were really a
wide
change of things you know ways that
families dealt with this but the vast
majority of children
we're not educated and and those who
were old enough often went to work in
the fields with with their parents
typically picking tobacco because you
know that more hands meant more money
and a lot of those kids who were old
enough to work you know never returned
to school so the whole time that the
schools are closed court cases are
making their way through the system and
I think black members of the preserved
County community and n-double-a-cp
attorneys really had high hopes that the
Kennedy administration would quickly
resolve this issue and I think I think
the kennedy has spoke specifically about
Prince Edward and I do believe that the
JFK I'm gonna wanted to to be able to be
of help to them but he found once he was
in office that he really did have to go
through the court system as well and so
he and his attorney General Robert F
Kennedy you know were met with a lot of
frustration in that way and finally John
F Kennedy told you know his brother that
you've got to do something about Prince
Edward and we have to address it in some
way and so Robert Kennedy appointed one
of his assistant attorney generals to
come to Prince Edward and to come up
with a solution and they did come up
with a solution for that fifth year that
schools were going to be closed they
were able to open a school known as the
free schools and it was funded with
Foundation money donations and it was
going to be an integrated school and had
integrated board that oversaw it and
many teachers from New York and around
the country offered to come in and teach
and they did really innovative teaching
styles where you know kids were grouped
according to ability and could could
move no they weren't booked grouped by
age but rather by ability and so as they
caught up in certain subjects they could
move but this you know so this provided
a solution for the fifth year and they
were able to get County officials to
agree to let them use certain public
buildings in order to do this and to you
some of the public school systems buses
so that's what the fifth year looked
like and while and while the school was
open during the fifth year a Supreme
Court decision was handed down that
actually you know required that schools
be funded and that is what led to the
schools finally reopened 1964 they had
to reopen and be integrated and so you
know but with his white schools still in
place and becoming more permanent by the
moment you know during that five year
period the schools went from being just
in church basements to a building being
built for a high school you know and
plans to have permanent buildings for
you know K through 12 and so when the
schools did reopen there were very few
you know white students in attendance
and they reopened that that black high
school you know exactly where it had
been and it was now open as everyone's
high school so I grew up in Prince Harry
County Virginia and my family is all
from there and I attended the white
Academy which was called Prince Edward
Academy at the time and my parents as
children they they were growing up when
the schools closed and they were both
sent to those church basements and the
Rotary clubs to attend schools and they
ended up both graduating from rhetoric a
demean and moving back to FarmVille and
deciding to raise me and my three
brothers there and deciding to send us
the Academy which was still segregated
so I grew up there in this place of the
rich history of the Brown versus Board
of Education decision the walk out you
know the only community in the nation to
you know push back to desegregation in
this way by closing schools for five
years and not knowing you know the story
not knowing that it's just something
that wasn't taught you know in the
private school and my friends in the
public school say it wasn't taught there
either it's part of a denial of history
right I think a lot of white leaders
there feel like they've said they're
sorry you know what more can we do
there's a desire to kind of push this
history
to the rug because it's painful you know
and I think you know so many of the
black families that I talked with
students who were shut out of school you
know they really hadn't talked about
this with their own siblings like
siblings had never sat down at the table
and said what did you do why the schools
were closed I remember you know I was
sent here to live with a nod but what
was your life like because different
siblings had different experiences based
on how old they were and you know
whether the parents could afford to send
more than one child away or you know in
their age so it was also a story that
black families didn't really want to
talk about because it they're really
still so wrong about it it's still so
painful and so I want people you know to
understand exactly what happened there
and the key role it played in American
history but I also want them to
understand that it's okay to confront
these hidden histories these shameful
parts of our of our history and to
really grapple with them and that's
something that that we are going to have
to do as a country to be able to move
forward
built in 1741 st. John's Church was the
first church in the city of Richmond it
gained notoriety in March of 1775 when
the second Virginia Convention was held
there and attended by colonial leaders
and future founders George Washington
and Thomas Jefferson it was here that
Patrick Henry gave his famous give me
liberty or give me death speech which
helped spark the beginning of the
American Revolution we continue our
special feature on Richmond with
Professor Jack Trammell and his book the
fourth branch of government the fourth
branch of government is actually a
contested term some people refer to it
as the media but my co-author and I
would like to co-opt that and reinvent
the fourth branch to be the power of the
people and we believe that America has
grown to the point where our democracy
needs to grow some too and the fourth
branch is the people's branch it's the
people's participation in our government
and democracy
I think guy's premise for what he wanted
to put in the book came from his
experience as an ordinary citizen in our
democracy experiencing some of the
frustrations and with partisan
partisanship and the failure of the
two-party system and gridlock and
government and so on for me my
perspective changed after I ran for
Congress in 2014 and Eric Cantor's old
seat it opened my eyes to the
dysfunctionality of many things in our
democratic processes as well as our
government part of the disconnect comes
from the fact that we're in uncharted
territory we've never been a nation of
this many millions of people we've never
been a nation that has an economy that's
moved from manufacturing into services
and technical side of the economic
equation we've never had a democracy
that had to function with this much
diversity and this many complications in
the worldwide economy so we need we need
a democracy that's able to adapt to this
new world that we live in and
unfortunately it seems like we're stuck
in some of our old ways to cite just one
example we haven't made a meaningful
constitutional amendment in almost 50
years
and yet on average we've amended it
every 20 years or so and so we seem to
have lost the ability to keep changing
and that seems to me to be one of the
key problems right now
the role of social media has really
impacted our democracy and the way our
election immerse in campaigning I before
2014 when I ran for office I viewed
social media as kind of a a funny
distraction but in my campaign our
social media transformed from pictures
of me kissing babies and meeting with
people in retirement homes and instead
became an active place where the debate
took place between the opposing
candidates and where issues were fleshed
out in meaningful ways and this
transformation took place over four
months and was significant and by the
end of the campaign social media was one
of our main vehicles it was difficult
for example for me to debate with my
opponent to establish that protocol and
to get him to agree to it but we had
quite a vigorous debate on a daily basis
in social media through our campaigns
and then more recently in the Trump
presidential campaign we've seen yet
another level of innovation in the use
of social media and whether you like it
or not I think we will see that it will
have transformed the way we're going to
be doing elections from here on out my
co-author and I would like to suggest
that social media also presents an
opportunity for people who can
participate in democracy at a higher
level and we would like to see
technology updated in the way that
people participate Evo ting is something
we have a chapter devoted to but there
are many other ways technology can
become involved as well the chief
benefit in the most general sense is
that this is the convenience we live our
lives with I shop on my smartphone I
take online courses on my smartphone I
pay my credit card bills and do my
banking on my smartphone and of course I
network with people why can't I
participate in my democracy through my
smartphone now in terms of social media
I can of course have an opinion and be
involved with people but guy and I would
like to see a more formal level of all
where we actually implement Evo ting and
allow people to participate in democracy
through their smart technology there is
resistance to Evo ting for example as a
form of technological participation in
democracy the resistance is primarily
centered around security concerns but
guy and I argue that if people want to
try to sway an election in a fraudulent
way technology is not the only way for
them to do that and so the problem is
the motivation of people and not the
technology itself and we've actually
interacted with some people at the
University of Virginia for example who
believe that it's very possible to
implement a safe form of a voting that
is almost a hundred percent fraud free
it involves some technical things that
I'm not adept with but when it's
explained to me it makes perfect sense
I think the resistance also comes from
the fact that we've been in about fifty
years of gridlock where we're just not
willing to look at the Constitution
we're not willing Congress's passing
half the laws they did 50 years ago more
complicated world less work from
Congress and so we feel like we need a
breakthrough of some sorts and
technology is one way we can do that I
think technology has had both positive
and not so positive impacts on political
activism on the one hand social media
and other forms of technology have made
it much easier for people to get
involved in just a few short minutes
having an opinion contacting someone
joining a crowd online so to speak but I
think it's also discouraged people from
some of the traditional ways of being an
activist for example we're standing here
in Richmond as the General Assembly is
meeting and we have lots of people next
to us who are coming in to meet with
their delegates or their Senators and I
think nothing replaces that face-to-face
contact and so there is a downside to
the technology but this is the world we
live in and we need to make it
compatible with our democratic processes
and we need to make it easy for lots of
people to participate with the
implementation of a voting I think it's
a little bit different than just
standard issues around social media I
think Evo ting is an access issue in
the Frontier Days access mint court day
and driving 20 or 30 miles in a wagon to
get to the county seat and making sure
you've filled out a paper ballot and
stuffed it in the box our tools are
different today but the process is the
same we just want to make it easier for
people to actually vote I still feel
like there are many obstacles too many
people making it difficult for them to
vote
Annie voting would be a way for us to
make it much easier for the vast
majority of people to participate even
an off-year elections and particularly
local elections and there have been some
locales that have experimented with a
voting and the sky has not fallen and so
it may be time for us to try it at a
state level or to try to look at this a
little bit more closely
I see technology and democracy as
evolving if we go back to 2008 and when
President Obama ran his first campaign
we saw innovation with social media in
that campaign it was a grassroots
campaign it was a populist movement with
lots of wide bases across the country
across many states and social media fed
into this it actually was more than
cheerleading it actually helped grow the
movement then in 2016 we've seen another
evolution with this to another level
where we're actually counting who has
more followers we're keeping track of
who tweets what in terms of factual
content and so I think in 2018 2020 in
the presidential election we're likely
to see a further evolution of this and
the question is how can we use this
social media to get the ordinary person
more involved in our democracy and in
our elections in the case of President
Trump I think most people realize by now
that he is the one typing on his
smartphone and sending it out all days
all hours of the day and night and this
again was something new in presidential
politics as far as I know and I think
there's an upside to that I think in
terms of populism there were a lot of
people who respected him for that and
felt like they were able to connect
him personally that there weren't layers
of campaign staff that that were
filtering what he was saying and the
fact that he occasionally had a misstep
with what he said actually endeared him
to some people now the flip side of that
and I fall into this camp I that
somebody who's a candidate and
ultimately became president should be
very thoughtful about what they put out
in the public space and impulsivity and
Twitter sometimes don't mix so I think
there's an upside to it and a downside
to it I think one reason it's difficult
to for people to get involved beyond
their smartphone or beyond their social
media is that in the last few decades
we've really become programmed to live
our lives through that technology and
through social media my wife and I have
a rule that once a week on date night we
can't take our our phones with us and I
think politicians need this role too
sometimes all of us perhaps but I think
this technology has become so ubiquitous
so commonplace that we perhaps are
losing track of some of the other things
that we need to do in a democracy we
need to have face-to-face conversations
we need to have groups of people
actually be together physically see each
other react to each other in real time
be able to see body language be able to
understand what people are saying in
context and politicians do you engage in
this during campaigns they meet with
crowds they meet with people but I think
social media on the downside has a
tendency to disconnect us from that for
people who read the fourth branch of
government what I'd like for them to
take away is that our founders were wise
they gave us tools and so we should not
feel helpless now we may not all agree
on what those tools should be there may
be people who think that Evo ting is
just not practical in the book we argue
that the electoral college is out of
date but I'm sure there are people who
argue that it is very necessary and
important the point is we need to have
these conversations because we've
stopped updating our democracy and yet
the world has continued to change so the
main message in the book is that we need
to be ready to change
and it may not be this and it may not be
that but we need to have a conversation
about it because if we stay where we are
we'll fall further behind book TV is on
Twitter and Facebook and we want to hear
from you tweet us twitter.com slash book
TV or post a comment